And we're alive.
How are you sir?
How are you?
Good to see you again.
I'm thrilled to be here.
Thanks for doing this,
man.
Thanks for having,
no,
I should tell you before we get started,
I did not know when I asked you to come back on that you were heavily involved
in this whole vaccine debate.
What I wanted to have you on to talk about as tropical diseases because a,
I remember when we did that Scifi show,
um,
you explained to me that some ungodly percentage of people that live in tropical
climates are infected by parasites.
That's right.
Well,
my day job is developing vaccines for tropical diseases.
We developed the vaccines no one else will make because they're for the world's
poorest people.
So if we call them tropical diseases,
but there really are diseases of poverty.
The vaccine issue,
the,
the advocacy issue around vaccines and autism is kind of a new thing that I got
drawn into just because I'm a parent of an adult daughter with autism and I make
vaccine.
So it was a natural that I'd get drawn into it.
Yeah.
So when I said that you going to come on,
then I got inundated by people that are,
you know,
the,
the vaccine thing is such a polarizing issue.
Yeah.
It's awful.
And so many people seem to think they absolutely know what causes what,
especially when it comes to something like autism,
which is a,
it's a huge issue in this country.
It's a huge issue around the world.
And it didn't use to seem to be,
the question is,
was that because it was undiagnosed?
Was that because it just,
there's,
it's more prevalent today.
What do you think,
what is your take on,
well,
I don't think we really know.
One thing's for sure.
We're diagnosing people with autism who we diagnosed as something else in the
past,
you know,
whether it was,
really horrible diagnosis,
we'd use pejorative terms like mental retardation.
What's amount of Jamie
just telling you the clock was off.
Oh,
okay.
Sorry.
Should we start again?
No,
no,
no.
It's okay.
He was just saying,
he was just telling me that there are clock is screwed up because of the
daylight savings time.
Right.
Sorry.
Totally unrelated.
To what you're,
all countries clack is screwed up because of the daylight saving.
Yeah.
Right.
Um,
so,
so we don't know.
We don't,
well,
you know,
one thing is clear that the number of diagnoses is going up,
but part of that is because what we used to call pejorative,
things like mental retardation now get thrown into the autism category.
The other thing now it absolutely so,
well you know,
now we call it as part of the autism spectrum.
Um,
we also,
because autism often has a lot of associated intellectual disabilities.
Not always,
but sometimes the other is that,
um,
can I pause is that based on aptitude tests?
Like how do you,
how do they decide?
How is it that,
what's autism?
Yes,
they have a list of diagnostic category,
but it's not crazy.
It's not like you can test
someone if they test positive for a disease.
That's right.
Well it,
although,
you know,
one of the interesting side pieces to this is,
the,
there's a group of people out there who self identified themselves as the
autistics and they get very resentful or hurt when they're called a disease or
disorder because they say,
well,
we're not an epidemic where we're a person and they,
it's part of this whole neurodiversity movement,
which is quite an interesting neurodiversity movement,
right?
They say their neuro diverse,
that they,
you know,
maybe think differently from others and they respond differently than others,
but they're not quote abnormal.
And,
and I think they have a good argument.
Um,
I heard a crazy argument once with someone that was so,
the point is that it's,
you know,
the,
the impairment like Rachel my daughter,
it's not so much her autism that,
uh,
torture,
you know,
ability to have partners or to,
uh,
have a meaningful career.
It's the fact that she has profound in hurricanes,
profound intellectual disability that goes along with it.
Um,
I forgot what I was gonna say.
So when,
when they say that people have us,
there's a spectrum,
right?
And some people who are autistic have an incredible abilities.
That's right.
They have incredible mathematical abilities,
musical abilities,
language abilities.
And then some people do not.
And some people have
Gitelman issues.
Yeah.
With Rachel's case,
my daughter,
it's a,
she has a pretty good verbal Iq,
80,
90,
but she has a very low performance Iq and 40,
she can't do simple math.
She can't count money.
Uh,
fortunately goodwill industries came to her rescue in our rescue and now she
works there two hours a day sorting clothes and,
and that's been really meaningful for her to get a paycheck.
Even if it's just to do something and feel and feel part of the mix.
That's huge.
That's huge for everyone.
Wraps little.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Um,
but so there's no,
uh,
there's,
it's not like you can test positive for syphilis or you can test positive for
the flu.
Right.
Although now,
you know,
as I say,
so that's why I don't like using those,
those terms because it,
it puts people on the autism spectrum as though they have a disease or a store,
which I don't like to do.
But if it,
if it is a disorder now,
well you know,
now we know there are 99 genes that are linked to autism,
but why is it a bad thing to say that you have a disorder if it's just a
disorder and when people have disorders,
let's the fact,
well you know,
a lot of the individuals in that,
that self identify themselves as the autistics don't like to think of themselves
as a disorder.
They like to think of ourselves as different.
It's different but not necessarily as a disorder.
Right.
But that doesn't help us when we're trying to discuss it.
Does it?
Yeah,
it gets very,
it's hard.
It's hard.
It gets hard to talk about it.
Well,
it also,
they're,
they're trying to stop you from talking about it in a certain fashion,
which is actually accurate.
Right.
When they have an issue,
there is an issue to say there's no is kind of ridiculous.
It's,
I mean,
there's a reason why so many people are so concerned about autism and vaccines
and just autism in general,
whether it's in an environmental pollution factor as well,
literally like to do is they like to make the distinction between autism,
that neuro diversity thing and actually having intellectual disabilities that go
along with it.
Okay.
And maybe it's a bit of semantics also,
but they feel strongly about it right now.
If we don't know what causes autism,
what we do,
we do well.
We're getting there very closely,
CIF.
So we've now,
there is a very important paper produced,
uh,
written by group at the broad institute,
Harvard,
Mit,
which is one of the premiere genetics genomics organizations in the country.
And they've now identified 99 genes.
It's a,
it's a huge team of scientists,
not only at the brode,
including piece scientists at Baylor College of Medicine,
99 genes involved in autism,
all involved in early fetal development,
uh,
early brain development,
in the first and second trimester of pregnancy.
So now we're starting to really get our arms around what autism is.
And that's one of the things I talk about in the book.
I mean we,
we have learned so much in the last couple of years about autism,
how it begins early fetal development well before a ever received vaccines.
And that's one of the reasons I saved vaccines.
Did Not Cause Rachel's autism vaccines don't cause autism because autism is
already underway in early or early brain development.
Is it possible that some people have this tendency towards autism and it's
exacerbated by vaccines?
I don't think so.
Um,
I think what happens is the sequence of events happens,
uh,
during pregnancy,
but the full clinical expression of autism often doesn't happen til 18 or 19
months of age.
Like Rachel for instance,
wasn't actually diagnosed till 19 months of age.
And there's some fat fabulous studies now showing that that clinical expression
of autism actually coincides with a big increase in the,
in the volume of the brain.
You can actually show on cereal,
magnetic,
magnetic resonance imaging,
serial Mri.
How the brain starts to the brain volume starts to increase and that's very
important because parents will often remember,
oh my kid got vaccinated are on 18 months of age or,
or 15 months of age and want to link the two.
But now you can go back to six months of age and this is studies done at the
University of North Carolina Chapel Hill showing so that you can do an Mri at
six months of age and they can predict now with they say with 90% accuracy which
of the kids will go on to develop autism and then you can take it.
What are they seeing?
What?
What are they saying?
They can see I have,
you have to go,
we can go into detail on the paper,
but they can see certain things on signatures on Mri that tell them that this
kid is going to go on to develop policies.
In fact,
there is a way to test positive for autism.
Then with this serial Mris,
that's what they think.
Right
now we have the 99 gene.
So we can even take it back further by doing what's called whole exome
sequencing,
all the DNA,
all the express DNA of an individual.
And in Rachel's case we did that and we actually found the mutation in a gene
controlling a neuronal connections,
which makes a lot of sense if you think about what autism is.
Yeah,
of course.
So,
so there is a way to,
to show whether children will be more likely to develop autism.
And there's there,
there is a way to,
to look at their brain through Smri at a very early age and,
and also do the Anisah do genetic sequence.
So it's not simply a matter of how they perform on cognitive tests.
That's right.
We're getting much better at getting our arms around the diagnosis.
Why do you think there's so many people that have these anecdotal stories of
their child getting vaccinated?
Especially large doses of vaccines when they hit him with like 10 in a row and
then all of a sudden or measles,
measles,
mumps and rubella is the one that gets repeated over and over again.
That's the one that made my child have autism.
I've heard that so many times,
and I've heard it from friends from friends that have children that have autism,
they had a child,
their child got the measles,
mumps,
rubella shot,
and then immediately there was a very distinct change in the child's behavior.
Well,
no question.
When you get the measles,
mumps,
rubella vaccine,
many times kids cry and,
and things like that.
And then autism will then begin sometime between the first and second year of
life.
So it's logical to want to connect the two.
But now we know it's not even plausible because we know that if you go back to
that an MRI at six months of age or go back prenatally,
we can even determine which kids are going to go on to develop autism.
So even though this and that complementing it,
complementing it are massive epidemiologic studies done on over 1 million kids.
In fact,
a new paper was just released this week showing that kids who get the Mr get the
MMR vaccine are no more likely to get autism than kids who don't,
who don't get the MMR vaccine.
And the converse is also true.
Kids on the autism spectrum or no more of likely to have gotten the MMR vaccine
and kids not on the autism spectrum.
Okay.
So,
so it's the combination of that,
those big studies of over 1 million kids together with knowing what autism is,
that completely rules out the possibility.
Right.
So these genes,
excuse me,
the,
and the issue with these genes and then the ability to scan the brain with the
serial Mri and the,
so you can tell which children have the propensity.
Is it possible that children have all these issues and then do not get autism or
do 100% of those children with those issues get autism?
That's a good question.
Uh,
I don't know.
I'm a vaccine scientist,
so I'm,
you know,
the inaudible well,
well,
I'm a biologist,
but on the vaccine scientists who,
who's really tried to do a deep dive and autism doing research on the book
versus Human Development.
Right,
right,
right.
Okay.
So,
uh,
so what you're saying though is that if a child does not have these mutations
and does not have these issues that are present during serial Mri,
that they will not go on to develop autism.
Is that true?
As far as we can tell as far as we can tell.
So children without those issues who get vaccinated have have no problems,
which most children have no problems.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean the,
you know,
we've learned a lot about the,
the risk of vaccines and the numbers are extraordinary.
I mean,
the risk of a severe adverse event happening after getting a vaccine is roughly
on the order of one in a million between,
between one in 1,000,001 in 10 billion.
Um,
so,
and I found an Internet report wants us to delight.
Likelihood of getting struck by lightening is one in 700,000.
So it's,
you know,
the likelihood of having a severe event after a vaccine is your best odds are
better,
uh,
of getting struck by lightning than,
and when you say severe event,
what do you mean by severe event though?
Oh,
wow.
The,
which is actually a table that's put out by the National Vaccine Compensation
Act.
Um,
that includes,
um,
uh,
shoulder injury.
Uh,
that's one,
uh,
encephalitis,
shoulder injury.
Yeah,
that's actually on from the actual injection point put,
getting,
injecting it in the wrong place.
Oh,
so it goes into the joint or something like that?
Yeah.
Is that common?
No.
So there,
there have been issues where children have adverse effects and reactions to
vaccines.
What do you attribute those to?
But when you know,
one in a million,
I think,
you know,
in some cases,
biological variability,
I think in some cases inadvertently,
if it's a live virus vaccine,
like the measles,
mumps,
rubella vaccine,
and you have an underlying immune deficiency that wasn't picked up before,
then that virus can replicate better,
but very rare things like that.
Right.
So as far as,
you know,
children who are healthy,
who get a vaccine,
it's,
it's not biologically possible for them to develop these traits,
these mutations in the genes and these issues that you see present as best we
can tell.
Right now,
that seems to be the case,
right?
As best you can tell right now.
It's a,
it's a great thing to say I,
but for people that are like,
hmm.
On the outside,
like what does that mean?
I'm not a doctor,
I'm not smart enough to understand what doctor Hotez is saying right here.
What does he say?
What I'm best as we can tell?
How much can we tell?
So here's what we can tell.
Okay.
No,
um,
studies number 1 million children that there's no link between vaccines and
autism,
that's number one.
And,
and so let me Parse,
how do they,
let me parse this out into bits.
So there's,
there's the studies on a 1 million children showing that vaccines do not cause
autism.
That's part one.
The second is that,
but then,
then I'll do,
and then I'll do a deeper dive on each of them.
The second part shows not only is their massive evidence that there's no link
between vaccines and autism,
there's no plausibility because we know so much about autism,
how it begins in pregnancy.
Okay,
so guts go back to the first part.
The first part is studies and over 1 million children.
One of the things that the anti vaccine lobby does is they played this game of
what I want.
It's not really a game,
but what they call,
what they do is play this kind of a thing of vaccine whack-a-mole.
Because at first they alleged it was the MMR vaccine and that came out out of
the study that was published in the Lancet in 1998 then another group came along
and said,
no,
we didn't mean the MMR vaccine.
We meant to thrive.
Marisol preservative that used to be in vaccine and the scientific community,
not only up debunked,
the MMR linked,
they debunked the thigh,
Marisol link.
Then the anti vaccine lobby came along and said,
no,
we didn't mean that.
We're spacing vaccines too close together.
Then they changed it to get around again saying,
now it's the alum or aluminum in vaccines.
So,
and then each time the scientific community responds with massive epidemiologic
studies showing just absolute,
none of those things are true.
And do you think that it's just when you look at,
say if there's one in a million that has an issue with this and there's,
it's not autism.
So whatever those issues are that they hear these stories and these stories do
accumulate because there's 300 plus million people in this country and over 10,
20 years of one in a million,
you develop a significant history of cases where children did have issues with
vaccines.
So these people hear about these stories and people are terrified.
Obviously you're,
I have children,
you become very over protective of your children.
We worry a lot.
And then you also don't know,
like why do they get so many shots all in a row like that?
Why does a baby get 10 shots in a day?
That seems crazy.
Well,
I don't get 10 shots in a day.
Most of them,
most of the vaccines are now combined.
So for instance,
in one vaccine we can vaccinate against Diptheria Pertussis,
tetanus,
polio,
uh,
haemophilus influenza type B,
which is a terrible cause of meningitis.
And in some cases now even hepatitis a one shot is protected.
All these things combined and there's all sorts of studies showing that it's
safe to combine them in and it's fantastic.
Now you can vaccinate with one shot against six diseases.
So,
and these are life threatening disease,
right?
So the only concern is the child's immune system when they're bombarded with
this one do.
So a lot of times it causes them as it'd be tired or they're gets sick or they
don't.
But the point is,
Demian system is not bombarded.
I think that's another kind of a misnomer that the are a misunderstanding that's
put up by the anti vaccine lobby.
We remember the child's gut,
the intestines and the respiratory tree is,
is this or Oregon's of antigen presentation.
A baby on average is exposed to hundreds of new antigens every day.
So the idea that you're going to quote overwhelm the immune system with a
vaccine against six diseases just doesn't make any sense.
Again,
this is all phony baloney stuff put out by the anti vaccine lobby.
Let's,
let's be clear.
The Anti Vaccine Lobby owns the Internet right now.
They've,
what does that mean?
What that means is they've got,
they've put out now by some estimates,
500 anti-vaccine websites.
So that every time you put the word vaccine into a search engine,
whether it's Yahoo or Google,
you're going to get anti-vaccine misinformation.
That's number one.
Second,
we know now it's amplified,
um,
social media like Facebook and other forms of social media.
So a third,
um,
you know,
look at the Amazon site.
I mean,
it's,
it's incredible.
So my book,
this book,
the good news is it's,
I think right now it's the highest rate of pro vaccine book on Amazon.
The bad news is overall it's ranked about 20,
because there's 19 other phony baloney anti-vaccine books.
So,
so the Amazon is the biggest purveyor now of anti-vaccine books.
And wait,
it gets even worse.
Then you also have,
now they've probably become politicized.
They have political action committees in multiple states,
lobbying state legislators about,
uh,
um,
fault,
but with plying them with false information about what vacs vaccines do.
So,
and,
and the problem is we don't have a robust system of pro vaccine advocacy to
counter it.
So we don't really hear as much as we need to from the federal government,
from the CDC,
from the search in general.
So unfortunately in this country,
that defensive vaccines false to a handful of academics like myself.
And you know,
I'm an academic,
I wrote a book.
What chance do I stand against this major,
uh,
media empire.
Why do you think that exists?
Why do you think there is this major media empire that's against vaccines?
That's a great question.
What's the motive?
What's the motivation,
number one and number two,
where's the money coming from?
Right.
There's real money behind this is millions of dollars behind this to put out
phony documentaries and phony books.
What's a good phone he documentary to point to?
Well,
I'm a little reluctant to do it.
Say it cause they're so litigious and,
and uh,
and you know,
I don't have the means to defend the lawsuit and things like that.
So go out there.
These,
um,
documentaries,
I'd usually don't mean specific aims are,
I understand these documentaries.
What do you think their motivation is?
Do you think they earnestly believed that vaccines do cause harm or vaccines?
Do Cards.
I,
I dumped me on autism.
I don't know.
I mean,
is there some kind of other agenda that they have?
we do know in some cases that um,
the some elements of the anti vaccine lobby or promoting phony autism therapies,
right?
They're doing terrible things like this.
Think called MMS,
which are bleach and Umas whites.
Yeah.
Bleach giving bleach enemas to kits.
You couldn't to children the children bleach,
bleach because they're cleansing the immune system.
There's cleansing them of toxin though.
It's really awful stuff.
And they're doing culation therapy,
which is very dangerous,
is that,
that's where they,
they claim,
you know,
kids are overdosed with toxic metals,
so they give a chemical that actually can collate the metal,
but it can kill it,
your calcium and then put you into a fatal Arrhythmia as well.
They're also who is doing this culation therapy.
You can Google or whatever,
search engine or these doctors like suns,
some cases there are doctors unfortunately or other health professionals.
And what is,
I mean,
I'm sure you've studied,
get some evidence late.
It gets worse.
There's no evidence.
And then,
and then they're doing hyperbaric therapy,
uh,
which is really bad.
So insomnia,
hyperbaric therapy is bad.
Well for it doesn't do anything for autism,
that's for sure.
But it's good for recovering from injuries and yeah,
there's certain selected sir.
But who knows what,
who knows what it's doing to a young kid.
Right?
I mean,
so,
so you shouldn't be doing that.
Um,
the then the other then that's one.
So how much of this is being driven by,
um,
financial motivation peddling these phony autism therapies?
I can't say.
My sense is that's not the big piece of this.
There's also some reports now Russian bots and trolls that are amplifying this
and sewing political instability in the country.
But again,
you add that all up the phony autism therapies,
the Russian bots and trolls,
to my mind,
that really doesn't get our arms around the big driver of this thing.
So I think we really need some good investigative journalist to look into this.
Well do you think that there's some sort of a concerted effort
or do you think that it's just a bunch of people that really believe that
vaccines do cause autism?
They don't truly understand the science and they haven't talked to someone like
you and maybe they have this idea that cemented in their mind and they're not
willing to look at it objectively and look at the full spectrum of possibilities
and look at the science behind what you guys are saying.
Because in their head they've been saying vaccines cause autism.
They had been saying it for so long,
the once someone gets that and they're connected to that,
it's very difficult for them to shift gears.
V People have a really hard time not being married to an idea.
Yeah,
no,
I agree that and um,
you know,
when I talk and I spend a lot of time going around the country giving,
uh,
what are called grand rounds lectures to hospitals and medical schools,
pediatric grand rounds.
So I've had the chance to talk to a lot of pediatricians and nurses and nurse
practitioner and even,
and more and more than a few parents.
My impression is most of the parents are who are,
who are called to be so called vaccine hesitant as the word of the day are not
really deeply dug in.
I mean,
you can,
you can have a conversation with him and explain to them like we're talking now
in a very nontechnical way.
You know,
the evidence showing vaccines don't cause autism.
The lack of plausibility given,
uh,
that it,
that it begins in pregnancy and they'll vaccinate their kids.
There is another percentage,
and I don't know what the percentage is,
whether it's 10,
15% that are deeply dug in and are wholly invested in this conspiracy theory
that the,
that the government isn't cahoots with the pharmaceutical companies and Blahdy,
blahdy Blah.
And then if you try to talk him out of it,
uh,
they just think you're part of the conspiracy.
So it's,
it's sort of a no,
no win approach there,
but,
but most parents,
you can have a good conversation with most parents.
It's not necessarily even most parents,
right?
I mean,
what,
what you're dealing with is these people that maybe they're into a bunch of
different alternate therapies,
a bunch of different kinds of cleansing.
And you know,
there's a lot of that nonsense that you find online where,
I mean,
look,
there's legitimate,
but I,
but I guess,
but I guess my point,
I'm sorry.
That's okay.
Please go ahead.
No,
but I guess my point is,
um,
parents don't get the chance because they're so inundated with phony
anti-vaccine information that could do a Google search or whatever,
you know,
whatever search they do.
So what do you think should be done?
Should there be a pro vaccine documentary?
That makes sense.
I think,
thanks for that question.
I think there's three things that need to be done.
I think first of all,
some of this anti-vaccine media empire needs to be dismantled,
dismantled,
and then decide whether the wrong or right.
Like,
shouldn't,
I mean it seems like there should be some sort of a debate,
right?
Like if there's someone who's saying that there's some evidence of vaccines
caused debates,
you're saying there's no evidence of vaccines cause debate now,
excuse me,
that vaccines cause autism.
And you're saying there's no evidence that vaccines cause autism.
There should be a debate where there some sort of a like some sort of a
monitored conversation where you can have you versus someone else and break this
down.
Yeah.
But that,
that has,
that's a two edge sword too because you know,
then it gives some fos legitimacy to the he anti-vaccine side.
It's like debating the smoking caused cancer.
Yeah,
but doesn't that,
isn't there already a problem?
I mean it seems like if there's this many,
if you do Google search and you're just overwhelmed with antivenom,
it seems like the fight has already been lost.
If that's the case.
That's right.
So giving them legitimacy,
it looks like it's not necessarily giving them a legitimacy.
It's giving them,
you give you rather a forum to dismiss their legitimacy.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think,
you know,
part of it,
what has to be done is,
I mean,
and,
and this gets into all sorts of first amendment issues,
and I'm not a lawyer,
but you know,
the,
the idea that Amazon now is putting out all of these phony books and phony
documentaries or they're just a distributor,
right?
Yeah.
They don't have to go over every book that they sell with a fine tooth.
Maybe they should,
I mean,
not fine tooth comb,
but maybe there should be some screening.
Maybe Amazon may be Facebook should all be hiring chief scientific officers to,
you know,
putting some stops on the dissemination of,
of information because it's harming children.
Right.
I mean,
this is the reason I get passionate about it.
Um,
the reason I actually wrote the book because it's kind of interesting.
I,
it actually happened before all of these big measles outbreaks that we've been
having.
Yeah.
I noticed that in Texas there was,
where I,
my laboratory is at Texas Children's Hospital and Baylor College of Medicine,
we noticed that there was a steep increase in the number of kids whose parents
were opting them out of getting vaccinated to the point where in Texas we have
over 660,000 kids not getting their vaccines in the state of Texas.
And those are the ones we know about.
We don't know anything about the 325,000 homeless school kids.
So we probably have over 100,000 kids and not getting vaccinated all because of
this misinformation campaign.
And I was really troubled by the fact that there was no response to it and that
drove me to write the book.
So the point is now Texas is very vulnerable to measles outbreaks.
And I say measles more than the others because that's the most highly contagious
disease.
What are the,
what's the danger of a child getting measles?
So is there any benefit to a child getting measles in terms of their immune
system?
No,
there's no benefit.
And that's one of the phony books they put out called Melanie's marvelous
measles.
I mean,
it's,
it's awful.
So,
um,
uh,
what did they say in that book?
They say build your immune system.
It does not.
It's remember,
um,
after,
so let's go back a little bit.
Smallpox was eradicated in the late 1970 through vaccination.
One,
smallpox was eradicated.
A kid,
Radica and measles was arguably the single leading killer of children globally.
2.6 million children died every year.
And measles because it causes measles,
pneumonia,
measles and cephalitis talk about permanent neurologic injury.
That's a bad actor.
Measles,
uh,
and then deafness at all.
And then through global vaccination campaigns,
we brought it down by the year 2000 to about half a million kids dying.
And then the gates foundation put up $750 million to create the Gavi alliance,
the Global Alliance for vaccines and immunization.
We brought it down now to 100,000,
but now measles is coming back.
Europe's a disaster right now.
We've got 80,000 measle cases in 2018 in Europe and now it's coming back to the
u s and so my worry is this me,
the anti-vaccine media empire is it started out as a fringe group,
but now it's really effecting public health,
allowing a deadly disease like measles to come back.
Do you think if there's some sort of definitive evidence that shows to the
general public like you could,
you could show it to them like this is what causes autism.
We've narrowed it down to these genes and it,
it has nothing to do with vaccines.
If you give these vaccines to people without these genes,
there is no way they're going to get autism.
They get autism specifically because of these variations in their chain.
You just,
you just summarize the book.
Right,
but I mean we by name more than a book,
right?
Yeah,
it does disturb me when I hear about all these kids getting measles and,
and not just
measles,
but means in some places polio has made a resurgence.
Well,
polio in now we're down to about three,
three countries that still have transmission a while type polio.
It's Nigeria,
Pakistan,
Afghanistan.
So hopefully we're getting our arms around polio.
But measles is now come back,
roaring back with a vengeance.
Having people contracted polio outside of those areas.
I mean,
those are the areas where it's,
every now and then some cases pop up.
We had some wherever and this could get it onto a whole nother topic.
Wherever there's collapse in health systems,
infrastructure such as during from war,
political instability,
these diseases can come back,
they can come back.
And the people that are vulnerable and children that are not immunized.
That's right.
And when you're immunized,
you're not vulnerable.
That's right.
Yeah.
This is,
it's a really confusing thing for people because on the outside they,
people always want to think that big Pharma.
But I've,
I've said some terrible things about big Pharma and the reason being is
painkillers because painkillers and antidepressants,
and there's the SSRI which are overprescribed and the painkiller one kills me
because I have no people directly that have been addicted to these goddamn
things.
And then doctors are passing them out like candy.
So people look at big Pharma as being,
oh,
these are the monsters that push this.
They're also the people that give you things that save people's lives.
There's a lot going on there.
Yeah.
I'm no,
I'm no big defender of,
uh,
of the big pharmaceutical companies.
I mean,
one of the things that the anti vaccs the insults at anti-vaxxers her at me as
they say,
I'm Michelle for industry.
They say I'm a secretly taking money from Merck and praxis with clouds.
All the crap.
You know,
I don't take a penny from them and I,
and I,
and it's not even how do you get paid just by the,
from the university and get paid by the university.
And some of that,
uh,
some of my salary is offset by not grants from nonprofit foundations.
Um,
then,
and this is because like the tropical,
right?
And then they say,
I'm secretly making millions of dollars for our vaccines for hookworm and
schistosomiasis and Chagas [inaudible] with all that money because my wife says,
if only that were the case,
right.
These are diseases of the poorest of the poor.
I'll never make a penny on these disease.
And in fact,
you know,
one of the frustrations I have with the big pharmaceutical companies is we've
gotten a lot,
made a lot of progress of their vaccines.
We've gone all the way from discovery through early phase process development
and manufacturing and I and d filing with the FDA,
investigational new drug applications.
But we're came in and kind of stuck at phase one,
phase two clinical trials because we don't have the big Pharma money to take us
all the way to licensure.
So I've had a lot of meetings with the big pharmaceutical companies to see if
they can partner with us.
And so far that hasn't happened.
So is has there ever been any discussion or any interest in creating some sort
of a,
a compelling documentary that's pro vaccination that can counter all of these
things?
Cause there's,
there's quite a few health related documentaries that I know are horse because
I've talked to actual real scientists and clinical researchers that say like all
these things they're saying are wrong and this is why they're wrong in this.
You could show this the wrong.
And then when someone says,
Hey,
I saw this documentary,
it says it,
all you should eat is toast.
They could say,
listen man,
you got to go here and watch this,
and it'll show you why.
That's nonsense.
Right.
Is there anything like that right now or was there any discussion?
Not right now.
There are some discussions,
but we're a long way off from that.
And the problem is the anti-vaccine documentaries are being distributed,
widely distributed,
widely sold,
and
and those people that are talking about it.
Here's the other problem.
Whenever I talked to someone about it was I've been doing this a lot lately
where I've talked to some of the about something they're passionate about.
I go,
what books?
We read on it and it's like,
wow,
I saw this documentary.
Well,
very good
and,
and there.
Yeah.
In fact,
there's 19 bullshit 19 ahead of mine,
right?
Books that are written by actual researchers,
people that have spent decades in labs understanding what's going on.
You don't really,
you know,
you don't get a lot of that from the people that are anti anything.
Right.
Well,
that's,
that's what I wrote,
the new book.
It's a very confusing thing for parents because you're scared.
You know,
you have this little tiny baby that you love more than anything in this world.
And then the doctor say,
Hey,
we've got this round of vaccines common and you're just terrified that you're
going to do something to your child's is we turn your child into a someone who's
compromise.
Yeah.
And the point is,
um,
the problem is these diseases are back now and so it,
the urgency to vaccinate is now more than ever.
I mean,
remember right now,
look what's going on in Vancouver,
Washington right now where the measles outbreak is underway.
The ones who,
who are at greatest risk,
our infants under the age of 12 months,
not yet old enough to get their vaccine.
So that if you're a parent right now living in Vancouver,
Washington,
you're terrified.
You're terrified about taking your baby out the Walmart or the public library,
that vaccine,
forget the vaccine,
right?
So now the disease is coming back because the older kids are catching it and the
anti vaccine lobby uses terms like personal liberties.
And medical freedom while we're the personal liberties of this parent now who's
terrified to take her in when you say his or her infant
anti vaccine lobby?
No,
I know that Robert Kennedy Jr is a,
he's a,
he's a big one.
He's a big one and he seems like a very intelligent guy.
How could he not be aware of the science behind this and what is he getting
wrong?
What,
what he's getting wrong is just about everything.
Um,
you know,
he's formed an organization called children's health defense and um,
and it start,
he had a press conference about it,
I think it was September,
October of last year.
It is probably one of the best organized anti-vaccine groups out there now he's
doing other things other than vaccines.
He's doing a lot of things about environmental health and things like that.
I don't know any part of that business.
I've only followed what the,
what he does with vaccines,
but it's all,
it's all nonsense.
Why is doing this about vaccines?
I don't know.
What's his,
well,
I mean,
you have to ask him what's his motive it would he be a guy that you would want
to have a debate with or have a discussion with?
But again,
I mean,
I'm uncomfortable with the idea of a debate because it's like,
it's like debating,
I dunno,
it's like debating a Holocaust denier,
whether the Holocaust exist.
I mean,
not that this rise,
I understand what you're saying,
but if you're,
again,
I want to bring this up.
If you're,
you're complaining there's 19 books ahead of yours that are anti vaccine books,
you've already lost the battle.
Like it's time to regroup and maybe regrouping would be confronting someone with
actual scientific information mean you are a real doctor.
You're a guy who actually studied this and you're a man who understands the
science.
You were legitimate academic.
You could,
you could actually put a dent in this with a real conversation.
Yeah,
potentially.
Potentially.
Yeah.
I mean,
what would he be able to say?
Like what is his take on it?
Well,
remember he's a,
he's an attorney.
He's a,
he's very clever,
right?
And right now he knows how to presumably knows how to do arguments in court.
And 1:00 AM I,
I'm a scientist.
Do you think that he wants to deceive people or do you think that maybe he's
just incorrect and his accumulation of data?
Yeah,
I can't say what his motivation is,
but,
um,
his,
uh,
his information is,
is highly misleading.
Hmm.
Now,
what else is he,
when you say the lobby,
is this an organized thing?
Good question.
Again,
we need somebody who really wants to do a deep dive in this and kind of dissect
out the pieces to understand.
Um,
but it's,
it's impressive what you've got out there in terms of the hundreds of websites
and the amplification on social media and everything else.
Is it,
are there just one or two or three groups behind it or is it a random collection
of organizations that that needs to be looked at?
That does need to be now what,
what do you think is causing autism?
And in your personal estimation,
do you think that it is a,
that there was a rise in the factors that are causing autism?
Or do you think that it's,
uh,
a rise in the understanding of these variables that contribute to it that you
could diagnose people with in that before there were previously undiagnosed?
So I think most of it is that,
that we're just diagnosing it more.
We're including individuals in the autism category that we didn't before.
And by the way,
the numbers are about to go up even more because we're getting better at
diagnosing girls and women with autism,
which was also quite interesting.
We used to say it was 10 to one boys to girls and now we know there are a lot
more girls and women on the autism spectrum.
It just that they're usually more verbal and they can camouflage it better,
but they have very high rates of Comorbidities,
like obsessive compulsive disorder,
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder.
A lot of the teenage girls with eating disorders now they're finding could
actually be on the autism spectrum.
So the numbers are about to go up again.
I mean that's just an example.
I mean is I guess what you're really trying to get at,
is it,
is it beyond that?
Is there,
is there a bonafide increase beyond the number of diagnosis?
And that one I'm still not sure about,
I wrote an article about early onset gender dysphoria being connected to young
girls with autism.
Right?
Yeah.
There's a disproportionate number of girls with gender dysphoria who turned out
to be also autistic and I've heard that as well.
Yeah,
that's actually,
so it's fairly fascinating to think about now.
Unfortunate and fascinating at the same time,
right?
There's,
there's um,
there's a nice paper by very good environmental scientists in Phil Landrigan who
used to be at Mount Sinai now,
I think he's at Boston College now and he publishes about five or six chemicals
in the environment,
which if you're exposed to for long periods of time during early pregnancy,
your child will be born with some features that resemble autism.
Do you know what those chemicals,
I have to remember all I talk about it in the book.
One of them is depakote.
Valproic acid,
which is a psychiatric medicine used as a mood stabilizer or an antidepressant.
So prolonged use of depakote during pregnancy has been linked to something that
resembles autism.
So that common medicaid,
it's a common medication.
Um,
but now that we know this information,
we don't use it anymore.
And so one of the things that I've been saying to,
you know,
people like Bobby Kennedy and everything else,
if you really want,
if you really think there's some environmental link to autism,
we've got a list of at least six chemicals during early exposure in pregnancy
that are probably causing mutations and things like that that are,
are leading to autism.
Why aren't,
and why isn't anybody looking into that?
It's just crazy.
I mean,
so all the focus on those into vaccines and it kind of sucks all the oxygen out
of the room so that,
you know,
really understanding the search for autism gets delayed or in some cases doesn't
get pursued at all.
Or the other thing that happens in many state legislatures and things like that,
the focus is so much about vaccines that we don't talk about what autism parents
really need.
I mean,
what do I need for Rachel?
We need,
you know,
employment counseling and help.
We need mental health counseling.
What do we do after we're gone,
Rachel?
Right now is living with us.
I'm s I turned 60,
my wife is,
you know,
58 what happens to us 10 15,
20 years from now,
there's no roadmap to so,
so all of that gets shunted aside because of these phony Baloney anti-vaccine
argument.
And that's why I get angry.
That's when I start to realize these guys in addition to affecting public health
are actually hurting autism families as well.
Well that makes sense.
I mean,
I can completely understand why this would upset you,
especially as a scientist.
Now when you're talking about these,
uh,
various chemicals that you think do contribute to or possibly cause autism,
um,
maybe we should really concentrate on that and publish something about this.
Is this something that,
is there an article that people can go to that says something about this?
I talk about it in the book,
in the book,
and I could,
if I opened up the book,
I could provide it for you.
But is there anything that people can read online about this without going to
your book?
I'm probably,
you know,
one of the problems that we faced in this country is that we put a lot of
scientific articles behind pay walls,
which is a real source of frustration for me.
And that's what they do that,
well,
one of the reasons,
one of the things that I've done now is,
um,
I'm one of the,
uh,
I founded a,
an open access journal called the public library science neglected tropical
diseases so that anybody with a computer,
you know,
an Internet connection and a printer can download the articles for your charge.
And we need more of that.
That's great.
But right now if someone wants to find out these chemicals,
they have to buy your book or by some sort of access to scientific papers,
I'm not sure what that particular paper,
whether it's behind a paywall or not,
I'll have to look.
Yeah,
I mean,
besides measles,
uh,
what other diseases are more prevalent now because of people not vaccinating
their kids?
The ones that,
there's three diseases that I worry about the most,
actually four,
well,
whooping cough is another one.
So that's one.
But the other one I worried about as the flu vaccine,
kids aren't getting their flu vaccine.
Last year in the 2018 flu epidemic,
150 unvaccinated kids died of influenza despite the recommendation of
vaccinated.
Can you enlighten me on this?
Because what I've been told is that sometimes they get the flu vaccine wrong so
you can get vaccinated,
but it doesn't,
doesn't protect you for the strain of flu that everybody's getting.
Well.
So that's again,
something that was heavily an idea that was heavily pushed by the Anti vaccine
lobby.
Here's the story.
Uh,
you're right lashed partially right last year the,
there was not a perfect match between the,
between the,
the virus in the vaccine,
the killed virus and the vaccine and the wild type flu strain that was out
there.
But it was good enough to prevent you from dying and it was good enough to would
likely prevent you from being hospitalized.
So it would have an effect even if you did get the right cause it was enough
cross protection so that it would,
it would mitigate the symptoms.
That's confusing to people because if they have the flu,
they say,
Oh,
well did it didn't work.
That's right.
But it did because it prevented you from getting sick and dying.
And,
and again,
that was,
that was a message that never really got out in 28.
Let's talk about someone like me who's a healthy person.
I've had the flu before.
Um,
but I don't usually get a flu shot.
That's crazy.
You should.
Especially now,
especially now as you're getting older,
because flu is,
uh,
one of the leading is probably the single leading infectious disease killer of,
of,
of adults in the United States.
But every time I had it,
it's really been like just a couple of days out.
I rest,
well,
you got a lot of fluids.
You got lucky.
My friends.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
taking care of your immune.
I mean,
let's,
so if you look at the 80,000 adults who died in the influenza epidemic of 2018
in the United States,
you're right.
A lot of them had underlying,
um,
uh,
things like diabetes or,
or,
or noncommunicable,
you know,
cardiovascular disease or underlying respiratory disease.
Maybe they were smokers,
but that they're still,
but there's still thought,
which is still thousands of individuals who are perfectly healthy.
You died of influenza,
uh,
that we know.
So you and you don't get your flu vaccine,
you're taking a terrible choice.
And why not?
Well,
I mean,
what,
what are you risking by getting the flu vacs?
I'm busy,
Bro.
You know what I'm,
you know,
you know where I in know or I get my vaccination Walgreens,
uh,
even better.
Like we have a big grocery store chain in Texas,
a big supermarket called Heb to get it up the nose.
And again,
I get it,
I get the injection right.
The pharmacist,
the farm,
all of my vaccines I've gotten for the last few years have been given by the
pharmacist.
Interesting.
So it couldn't be easier.
Are you,
have you ever gotten the flu since you've been getting the vaccine every year?
Uh,
well,
you know,
I've gotten,
I've gotten sick with,
I would like a cold,
like a,
like a sore throat and feeling crummy.
Was that a mild case of flu?
I can't really tell.
Okay.
Um,
but you've never gotten sick right after you got a vaccine?
Some people do,
right?
No.
Some people do get a vaccine and then they have an adverse reaction to it.
Sometimes,
you know,
after getting your vaccine you can get,
get some soreness and you can feel maybe a slight fever for a few hours or a
day,
but usually it's,
you're fine.
What does that,
what does that,
yeah,
what does that fever,
why,
why are you getting a fever?
Because the,
the vaccine is stimulating the immune system and stimulating the inflammatory
system.
So even though you feel like you're getting sick because of the vaccine,
it's actually good for your immune system.
That's right.
And you're not really sick.
I mean,
it's nothing like is nearly as bad as getting the flu.
Um,
the other vaccine,
uh,
now that you're getting up there,
you have to start considering as the shingles vaccine.
Shingrix and uh,
that's a,
that's a great vaccine.
It hurts though for a couple of days.
Do you take care of your immune system and other ways?
Do you take probiotics?
Are you cautious about your diet?
Um,
I'm not as cautious about my diet is I should be,
I'm a junk food a holic.
Uh,
actually,
well that seems like a terrible thing for your health.
It is a terrible thing for my health and something.
My wife is working on it,
but that seems ridiculous for someone who works with health.
Yeah.
Sometimes man,
I just don't get it right.
How often,
but how often?
How often do I steal a bag of chips or something like bait garbage?
Uh,
I dunno.
No,
no.
Hopefully not every day,
but you know,
hopefully not every day.
Maybe a couple of times a week.
Oh,
that's what if the three,
Rachel,
my,
uh,
my daughter with autism,
that's like our thing is to go to the,
uh,
it's called the burger joint or to shake shack to get,
to get a cheeseburger was sticks the sneak
some fries.
So,
so you live in large,
we call it like that mouth pleasure.
So much.
You willing to sacrifice a little bit?
Yeah.
You know,
I,
you know,
I can,
I have to concede that's the case.
Well,
there's,
I mean I don't have to tell you,
but there's a large body of data that connects poor diet to a host of disease.
That seems like a crazy decision for a guy in your line of work.
There you go.
Sometimes the,
uh,
sometimes the,
it's not all brain,
it's uh,
it's something else.
But I mean,
if you ate healthy food,
I mean,
the thing is your body starts craving healthy food.
You start feeling it.
No question,
no question about it.
Do you take vitamins?
I don't take vitamins real.
Yeah.
Wow.
I think they do.
I don't think they're needed because most of the mat and the American and the
American up hold up,
hold up.
You don't think they're needed while you're eating junk food?
Well,
hopefully I'm not only eating junk food.
You know,
there's a large body of clinical research on the efficacy of vitamins,
especially vitamins,
d vitamins.
I have taken vitamin D for periods better.
The recommendation of my internist and dude,
what about essential fatty acids,
which are great for your brain,
fish oil,
all these different things that are fantastic.
I'm not going to argue with you.
He got you got it.
You got,
you got it over me.
You've got to listen to,
but it would,
you would have a much better argument.
You're making my wife stay here taking care of yourself 100% instead of you
still need your vaccines.
I'm sure you do,
but vaccines aren't going to prevent cancer.
No,
that's true.
Right?
It's true.
There's a lot of diseases or diabetes or cardiovascular disease or a lot of
these diseases are connected directly to die,
right?
Yeah.
Yup.
Come on.
And the other lifestyle change,
exercise,
sedentary life.
I tried to go on the treadmill for 30 minutes.
I do it.
Actually,
I'm pretty good about that.
30 minutes every morning I go for an actual walk.
It's more interesting.
I did that too.
So I don't know.
But I deal with 30 minutes on the treadmill in the morning and then I uh,
and my,
I take a long walk with my wife in the evening.
But you know the,
the thing that knocks the crap out of you to travel.
Yes.
I find that very frustrating because you don't exercise and then you eat,
you don't eat well and you don't control the Diet as well.
So that's um,
well I have a solution to that and eat well and exercise those,
those are solutions to that.
Just do it,
you know,
I treat it like I'm brushing my teeth,
I brush my teeth every day.
I exercise every day too.
So when I travel,
I don't have an option.
When I land,
I go to the gym.
This is how it goes.
I land,
I get in my hotel room,
I put my shorts on them.
Yeah,
I did that too.
I do that too when I see only wet.
Yeah.
If you have to do it,
if you,
if you say this is just what gets done right,
this is how you do it.
Yeah.
I try to be really compulsive about that.
So yeah.
I have it written out.
I know what I'm going to do it,
especially if it's The d Jay,
great.
If the hotel is a good gym,
the whole cow,
you know,
if they have weights in a bunch of deforest run outside,
if we don't have it,
you run yeah.
To,
yeah.
Not very well,
but no,
but you do.
Yeah.
We're going to get you healthy buddy.
Can't be pushing only chemicals in injectable forms to facilitate health.
Fair enough.
Yeah.
Right.
Not Chemicals are vaccines.
I'm sorry,
what's in them?
What?
I mean it's some sort of chemical now.
No other antigens,
right.
They're,
they're the fluid macromolecules.
What's the liquids?
Typically it would be céline or saltwater and right now,
um,
what is missing from,
uh,
today's vaccine protocol,
if anything,
in terms of diseases we should be vaccinating for.
But
yeah,
there certainly are.
Um,
you know,
one of them is a big,
big problem among young infants,
especially premature infants called RSV,
respiratory syncytial virus infection.
What does that come from?
It,
it's um,
you know,
it's a respiratory virus that peaks around the same time that flu does.
So it's a very severe respiratory illness.
So this is again,
one of those vaccines that's not a big moneymaker.
So the bill and Melinda Gates Foundation is trying to provide grants for
supporting that one,
that that's a good one.
And then there are all the diseases that affect poor people,
both in developing countries that even among the poor in the United States,
this book,
that's the next one called the marble health.
The next one.
So this is not released yet.
This is out.
This actually,
this actually preceded the,
Oh,
this one.
Now this book is all about poor people and infectious diseases and that the rise
of these infectious diseases even in the United States.
Right.
So,
you know,
when we think about,
so I,
I,
you know,
Le led this big campaign to raise awareness of somebody calling neglected
tropical diseases or NTDs.
These are the most common afflictions of people living in poverty.
Um,
I call them the most important disease.
You've never heard of their diseases like schistosomiasis and chagas disease,
leishmaniasis and had been devoting my life to seeing if we could develop
vaccines for those diseases in the nonprofit sector.
You know,
because the big pharmaceutical companies just don't see,
just aren't going to take these on.
So we're trying to do it in the nonprofit sector.
But this book,
the Blue Marble health book came out of some number crunching that I did using
data from the World Health Organization or something called the Institute for
health metrics and evaluation,
which is based in Seattle,
Washington.
That found something very surprising and that is most of the world's poverty
related diseases are not necessarily in the poorest,
most devastated countries of Africa,
meaning like Democratic Republic of Congo,
Central African Republic.
They're there.
But on a numbers basis,
most of these poverty related diseases are in the g 20 economies,
the 20 wealthiest economies,
um,
together with Nigeria,
which is not a g 20 country,
but as an economy bigger than the bottom three or four.
So that was pretty amazing.
An amazing for me to find that out.
Because you know,
at first I didn't believe the numbers because I said,
well,
how could it be if their poverty related diseases,
why are they in the 20 wealthiest economies?
And then I realized that it's among the poor living in wealthy countries.
So the poorest of the rich today now account for most of the world's poverty
related diseases.
And what's the cause of this?
So why,
why the link with poverty?
So that's a great,
so one of the things I do in the book is I asked that,
well,
what is it about poverty that's making susceptible?
I don't think we really know.
I mean,
clearly in some cases if you live in port dilapidated housing without window
screens,
things like mosquitoes and kissing bugs and sand flies can get inside the house.
Or if you look,
um,
in,
in poor neighborhoods,
like in and around Houston,
you see a lot of environmental degradation or on or on the neighborhood,
you see discarded tires that read it is chipped.
I mosquito or standing water.
But I think what,
what,
what did the tires do?
Discarded.
So yeah.
So one of the best habitats for the mosquito that transmits Danky and Zika and
Chikungunya and yellow fever are discarded tires.
That's what they love.
So this,
you know,
if you go into poor neighborhoods,
you'll see a lot of tire dumping for instance.
And that's,
those are habitats for that.
That ADC chipped I mosquito including here in southern California when the water
gets in the topics,
a little bit of white on it.
That's exactly it.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
I moved into a house once in a Encino down the street from here in fact.
And um,
uh,
no one had lived in the house for about a year and a half,
two years and the pool had not been taken care of and I went out into the pool
and it was green and there were schools of you heaven mosquito have is so
strange.
So yeah,
absolutely.
You going into poor neighborhoods,
abandoned swimming pools,
things like that.
That's,
that's where we're getting a number of these diseases.
We don't have very many mosquitoes in southern California.
I mean it's really kind of amazing in that regard.
Well it depends.
So you know,
at some counties where they do aggressive spraying and things like that,
you won't.
But in many counties you probably,
probably in some of the poorer counties,
poor districts you still do.
But I mean in terms of the way it is on the east coast,
like I grew up in Boston and in the summertime you just have fucking mosquitoes
everywhere.
They just can't get away from him.
And then I've been to Alaska,
which is the craziest place I've ever been to in my life in terms of mosquitoes.
Right.
Have you been,
I haven't been to Alaska,
but you get out of your car and they attack you like a,
a hoard of birds because they only get one month of the seat here.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So they're super aggressive and they're also very large.
The big problem along the Gulf coast of the U s we have that eighties jipped I
mosquito and that's why I got so worried about Zika virus hitting the golf coast
of the u s mosquitoes and other countries obviously contain malaria.
I mean,
we've been very fortunate that that's never made it over to here.
Well,
no,
we,
we used to have malaria.
He used to be widespread in the United States.
Um,
both the one that was a real killer disease called Falciparum Malaria on the
Gulf coast and even up into Illinois in the Ohio River valley.
We had a lot of malaria in the 18 hundreds.
In fact,
there's a whole,
there's a book written by Dickens when he visited the United States called
Martin [inaudible] Whitney when he describes all of these sickly people in
Illinois and k row Illinois and the confluence of the Mississippi and the Ohio
River.
He's clearly describing malaria.
Wow.
I did not know.
So what stopped it?
So that's a great question.
Um,
we,
so there's actually a very nice book written by a medical historian at Duke
University and they,
Margaret Humphreys called malaria race and poverty.
And she has a hypothesis,
which I think she's onto something that,
um,
it,
the decreased the malaria dropped in associated with aggressive economic
development.
Uh,
so that the,
the FDRs new deal included something called the Agricultural Adjustment Act that
got people off of,
off of with agrarian pursuits and put them into factories.
Quality housing went up and that's probably what caused a lot of the reduction
in these tropical diseases.
Remember,
they're really diseases of poverty.
In fact,
I spent a lot of time working in China and I'm seeing that play out right now in
China.
You know,
China is,
keds is very,
very aggressive program of economic development mostly in the eastern part of
the country,
but in the southwest part of the country going to Yunan Sichuan provinces,
you go back in time 75 years and you still see those diseases.
So spray.
Do you think that the best cure or the best way to stop malaria would be just to
increase the economy of these areas in Africa where they're experiencing it?
Clearly,
economic development is a very potent driver.
Now what it is about economic development.
We still don't have our arms around that yet,
but economic development is very important.
Just like for the neglected tropical diseases we study.
But you know,
unfortunately for many countries,
economic development is still decades away.
So that's why that's the rationale for developing these vaccines.
Is it because of economic development moves people into more urban environments
where there's less tropical diseases?
I think that's part of it.
Although now we're seeing some tropical diseases thrive and urbanized
environments like,
you know,
yellow fever and Zika and Danky as well.
So it's not only urbanization,
you ha has to be urbanization with good planning.
That's not done on check that out strips the infrastructure in terms of water
and sanitation.
So this brings me to the thing that I wanted to talk to you about in the first
place.
Cause this is what you brought up to me when we were doing this a Scifi.
And,
uh,
you said something to me that has been haunting me ever since,
that the vast majority of people that live in tropical climates have parasites
vast at jar.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
There's things like Toxoplasma Gondii.
And so let's look at the,
let's look at the hit parade,
right?
The top one is one called ascariasis intestinal Ron worm.
Uh,
the estimates are on 800 million people have asked Chris Round worms in their
bellies.
Well,
so hunter,
more than one in 10 people on the plant and mostly people who live in extreme
poverty.
Um,
400 million have hookworm infection.
400 million have whip worse.
A lot of these are wormy diseases.
200 million people with scabies,
which is an ecto parasite on the skin that causes terrible itching and,
and secondary bacterial infections.
Just to surmise,
this is another one.
The point is every,
almost every single person who is in extreme poverty has one of these,
what I call neglected tropical diseases.
And one of the interesting features about them is they're very debilitating.
They not,
so that not only occur in the setting of poverty,
but I think they reinforce poverty because they make people too sick to go to
work.
They make a,
they actually shape,
we can show they shave Iq points off of kids when they have them.
Well,
this is the hookworm connection to the idea of the slack jawed dumb southerner,
right?
Right.
United States of America.
And now one of the things that we have found,
so Ruh Rahalieo Mahia on my faculty,
uh,
working with an environmental activist named Catherine Coleman flowers and
Alabama found that hookworm is still present in Alabama.
So among the people,
so they understand what we're talking about because for the longest time there
was this stereotype about people that lived in the south,
that they were a dull minded,
right.
And that this could be dealt directly connected to hook worm infection,
which had run rampant,
right?
There was even the term given called,
they call it the germ of laziness.
Then hookworm infections because it causes severe anemia.
So if you're walking around with terrible anemia,
of course you're agreeing you're too,
you're not feeling up to working a full day and all that sort of stuff.
So hookworm was wildly president,
president in the southeastern United States at the turn of the 20th century.
And then as malaria went down with economic development,
so,
so did hookworm infections as well.
But we still have pockets in this country.
And this was an understood at the time,
right?
They didn't know that these people were infected with hookworm for,
for,
for forever.
No,
up until very recently.
So the cause of hookworm wasn't discovered til 1900 what is that cost?
It's called an Decatur Americana's.
The American killer as the,
and that's the name of the worm and this is what I'm walking barefoot or that
goes in through the hands or enters all parts of the body.
So it's very common to get it from walking barefoot,
which was more common in the south.
Right.
And so that's one of the diseases we've made a vaccine for this now in clinical
trials.
Yeah.
When I found that one out I was like,
oh my God.
Well that's it.
That totally makes sense because for the longest time was there,
there was that stereotype and then when you find out that it's directly
connected to a massive infection of this disease,
this worm,
so these are the diseases that are holding back,
people who live in poverty.
And originally I thought only in places like the poorest countries in sub
Saharan Africa or Southeast Asia.
But now I realize it's these pockets of poverty across the entire planet that
people are affected by these diseases and these diseases can be vaccinated.
That's where we're trying to prove that we could make a vaccine against.
And there is a hookworm vaccine right now in clinical trials just in clinical
trials.
Now,
wasn't there a Lyme disease vaccine?
But the problem was it was actually causing people to get Lyme disease.
So that's a talk about controversial topics.
So there was a Lyme disease vaccine that was developed,
uh,
actually from a colleague of mine at Yale University than it was,
and they licensed it,
I think it was to Glaxo Smith Kline,
and they developed it as they called it lime rex.
It was a,
the Lyme disease vaccine.
And actually most of the studies suggest that actually worked pretty well.
Uh,
the problem was there were a number of people who felt that the vaccine made
them worse,
or they said they had chronic Lyme disease,
that it wasn't effective.
So it was really a market perception problem more than anything else.
And ultimately,
uh,
it hurts the bottom line of the company and they,
they withdrew it from the market.
Friend of Mine's Dad got the vaccine and then got Lyme disease.
They think he got Lyme disease from the vaccine.
Probably not.
Probably is a weird word when someone with Lyme disease that's being nice.
No,
he didn't get Lyme disease and possible cause Lyme disease is caused by the Lyme
bacteria,
the spiral [inaudible] called Barellia Burgdorferi.
And the vaccine is not a live vaccine.
It's a recombinant protein based vaccine.
So it's not,
so there's nothing in that vaccine that could've caused this adverse reaction
that they directly attribute to that vaccine?
Probably not.
Again,
you're saying,
well I don't know the patient.
I don't,
and I haven't examined the Ngsi.
I hate taste where,
I mean that's the narrative that household,
well again,
you can know what's reinforced by a lot of negative information out there on the
Internet.
It's also reinforced by the fact they pulled the vaccine.
Yup.
Well,
they pulled the vaccine not because it wasn't working,
but because of market perception and,
and all that sort of,
and that was a time before the number of cases of Lyme disease have really taken
off.
So it seems strange to me because they didn't pull the measles,
mumps rubella vaccine because of perception.
Why would they pull the Lyme disease vaccine because of perception?
I think the reason was is because,
um,
the,
the cost benefit equation works a little differently.
Um,
with measles,
measles is a killer disease.
Lyme disease was not a killer disease and wrecking people.
Now in some cases it seems to be,
uh,
connected to a host of other ailments to correct,
like Lyme disease does.
It just exacerbates a bunch of different,
maybe,
possibly even existing health issues.
Well,
you have to be careful,
you know,
the,
and this gets into another controversial rabbit hole.
I'm not sure we want to get into or not today,
but,
um,
you know,
the Infectious Disease Society of America,
for instance,
has come out with a strong statement saying that there's really no such thing as
chronic Lyme disease.
And,
um,
the scientific evidence does not support something called chronic Lyme disease.
Yet there are lots of people suffering with chronic debilitating illness who
claimed that it's caused by Lyme disease.
Yes.
So this is something that,
um,
is out there right now.
Why is there a debate like what is it,
why are they saying that there is no such thing as chronic Lyme disease?
What's their evidence?
The evidence is that there's no evidence that they can detect spiral Keats in
the body in many cases,
uh,
people who have had Lyme disease don't have persistent evidence of having a
antibodies any longer to,
to the lime sparky.
So,
um,
it's a whole different area,
right?
But they do have this chronic inflammation and pain in their joints.
They have,
somebody starts breaking down,
they have something,
but it doesn't seem to the Infectious Disease Society of America,
uh,
which is one of the leading infectious disease bodies in our country.
And I'm not an expert on Lyme disease,
so I'm not too comfortable going there with you are saying that there's no
evidence that,
uh,
that that's actually associated with active infection with Lyme disease and what
are they,
how are they describing it and what,
how are they so another,
what's what,
so what's causing all the decent unknown unknown.
I know,
but isn't it bizarre that these same people got Lyme disease first and then how
about these host of issues afterwards?
Well,
the,
I guess part of the problem is in some cases they had Lyme disease first,
and in some cases they really didn't have Lyme disease.
Unfortunately,
there are a number of,
uh,
unscrupulous healthcare providers and even physicians out there that are making
the misdiagnosis.
Either they're making a misdiagnosis of Lyme disease or in some cases they're
actually taking everyone who comes through the door and diagnosing them with
Lyme disease.
I'm sure you're aware of the lone star tick.
Right.
And the allergy to red meat.
Yeah.
Right.
That's really fascinating.
Yeah.
And that's another one that's on the rise,
correct.
Yeah.
Well,
actually all tickborne diseases are on the rise now,
possibly because of climate change,
which is another factor in our country that's doing that.
So we're seeing,
uh,
you know,
if you'd look now at what are the big drivers of infectious diseases right now
in the,
in,
in not only in the US,
but globally,
there really some interesting forces.
And a lot of them are social determinants.
So a big one is poverty.
That's,
that's a huge one.
The other big one is political instability in war because it interrupts public
health control measures.
So for instance,
Venezuela,
which was leading public health control and Latin America for decades,
you know,
with the collapse of the economy and,
and the,
and the Chavez era now into the Madora area Madora area,
we've got a terrible situation where,
uh,
we've had measles return in a big way.
So huge numbers of cases of measles.
We fed all the neglected tropical diseases come back,
uh,
as well as malaria,
chagas disease,
leishmaniasis.
So it's really interesting how that is destabilizing the whole region because
now Venezuela has one of the largest diaspora is of people as big as the
diaspora coming out of Syria and Iraq.
So now that the diseases are moving into adjacent areas of Brazil and Colombia
and Ecuador,
and so it's really an,
and that's another big drivers,
political instability.
The third one,
uh,
we think is climate change may be very important.
So,
you know,
why did we see this big a surge of chicken gunyah virus infection in the western
hemisphere or Zika?
We don't really understand the forces of that.
And what's going on in southern Europe right now is quite concerning.
We've had malaria returned to Greece,
uh,
after it's been gone for 70 years.
Malaria's returned to Italy.
We're seeing schistosomiasis and neglected tropical disease on the island of
Corsica.
We've got,
uh,
Danky,
chicken Gunyah,
West Nile virus across Italy,
Spain,
Portugal.
So we're trying to understand why that is.
And there's some thought that climate change may be a big driver of that.
Now what other infectious diseases or parasites rather do they have vaccines for
two,
they have a vaccine for Toxo,
which there's no vaccine for toxoplasmosis.
Um,
there's a a prototype malaria vaccine that's,
yeah,
well it's,
it's an ex,
uh,
there's a malaria vaccine.
It's called Moscow Rick's,
that's the trade name that has developed a supported bud with a lot of funding
from the bill and Melinda Gates Foundation and,
uh,
working in partnership with glaxosmithkline.
And that malaria vaccine now has been approved for use in children by the
European medicine agency.
And it's being introduced now in three countries in Africa,
Malawi,
Ghana.
And I forgot the third one.
I think it was tense.
Is there an adverse reaction that people have?
That's tough.
Cause I know the traditional malaria medication.
I had friends that took it and had horrible nightmares.
Oem Laurium is terrible.
Yeah.
Gives you very lurid dreams and yeah,
no the so far,
no.
And so there,
when you say children,
how old are the children that they're at vaccinating with this?
Well,
the problem that you get into with malaria is that before six months of age,
you have maternal antibodies,
unborn human murder,
the word you're born with,
antibodies from your mother.
And those start to wane by six months of age.
So the ones who get hospitalized with measles was what's called cerebral
malaria,
which is a devastating condition or a severe malaria Nemea,
which is also a killer,
are those children between six months of age and five years of age.
So those are the ones that we want to protect now.
And it's one of the leading killers of children globally.
Right?
And we don't have the vaccine.
Sickle cell is connected to a crack,
right?
Sickle cell is,
it has something to do with,
uh,
people developing an immunity to malaria.
I'm surprised you knew that.
And it's not out from Tiffany Haddish who's Tiffany had it.
How dare you.
She's a very funny comedian,
so I'm sure she is,
but she's,
well,
she's really is like,
wow,
it's not really immunity,
but it's a natural protection.
So individuals who have the sickle cell trait are seem to be partially resistant
to malaria.
And that's the thinking why the gene for sickle cell has been preserved in
Africa for so long is because it does confer some protection against malaria.
So it's a reason for keeping the gene and the gene pool.
Yeah,
we were actually discussing it because a friend that I grew up with died from
it.
Um,
so it seems to only exist in African Americans or Africans.
Is that correct?
The predominant,
now that there's some other places as well,
but predominantly in African and among African Americans or people whose
ancestors came from these tropical climates where they price.
Yeah.
So it's pretty,
it's really quite an amazing story.
So,
um,
there's no,
no,
no.
Um,
vaccine for toxoplasmosis.
Is there anything on the horizon?
Is there anything we've been worked on?
Because that's a big one,
right?
It's a real big problem on people with HIV aids for instance.
That's a,
because it reactivates or toxoplasmosis and we even see it and I even see it in
kids sometimes,
but the thinking is,
activates it.
How so?
Well,
what happens is,
um,
it's in some countries up to 30% of people are actually infected with
toxoplasma.
And the parasite has the ability to undergo a dormancy state in the body until
your immune system gets compromised either because of AIDS or because if you get
some kind of a medicine that suppresses your immune system and then it can
reactivate it and cause what's called cerebral toxoplasmosis,
which is quite serious.
So most people handle or toxoplasmosis very well,
you know,
you,
you die with it and don't even know you have it.
But in some cases it gets reactivated right now.
Um,
there doesn't seem to be a lot of incentive for developing a toxoplasma most as
vaccine,
although I'd be very interested to,
to work on something like why would there be no incentive?
It's such a large scale disease.
It's hundreds of millions of people worldwide.
Right?
That's right.
And part of the problem is we have almost no information on the actual number of
people who have it and how extensive it is.
So we call that disease burden.
We don't have good disease burden estimates of toxoplasmosis get tested.
I've had a bunch of cats and I'm at feral cats and I'm crazy.
It's a good chance here your are infected.
But as long as your immune system's intact,
then you're okay.
Now there is a,
uh,
a related disease that from cats called toxic crisis,
and that's a parasitic worm infection we're finding in the United States among
the poor.
And that's a weren't.
So what happens is if you go into poor neighborhoods,
you know,
and uh,
you see a lot of feral cats and dogs and poor neighborhoods,
almost a hundred percent of them have this warm in their intestines and they're
seeding the environment with eggs in their feces and the feces are spread all
over the poor neighborhoods.
Kids come into contact with them and the worm has the ability to migrate through
the brain across the rebrand,
toxic crisis.
Um,
and I think it's an important cause of developmental delays.
It's one of those neglected diseases in the u s and talk about in the book and
there is no vaccine for that.
He was no vaccine for it.
And we know very little awareness about it.
Wow.
Yeah.
I've never even heard of it until just now.
So this is not rare.
I mean,
in some cases,
you know,
up to 10% of certain populations,
like African,
African Americans living in poverty are infected with it.
And it's primarily pets,
or does it,
is it rodents as well?
At least mostly stray dogs.
And it's not even pets.
It's mostly stray dogs and cats.
And I get very,
and this is an example of a neglected tropical disease.
Here's,
here's a disease of up to 10% of African Americans living in poverty in the
United States.
And almost nobody is studying.
Wow.
Right?
And it can affect the way your mind functions,
right?
It's,
and it's been linked now to developmental delays.
So,
you know,
everybody wants to know why,
kids living in poverty have developmental delays and people just assume it's
because they live in deprived environments and that sort of thing.
But I think toxic crisis is an important underlying reason for it.
Um,
and this is an example of a neglected disease.
You know,
we,
I mean,
everybody's heard of Ebola,
right?
And everyone's worried about Ebola and,
and the truth is Ebola is never going to come to the United States.
Why is it ever going to be,
cause it's too difficult to transmit.
Um,
unless you have a complete collapse in the health system.
We're never going to have Ebola epidemics in the United States,
but here's a disease of 10% of African Americans living in poverty and no one's
heard of it and there's no incentive to study it.
So that's why I'm trying to raise awareness about these poverty related
diseases.
And that's correct.
I mean,
I don't understand why people don't talk about that one.
Yeah,
that one seems insane,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's a no brainer.
Right?
And so,
but you know,
it's very hard to get people to care about diseases of poverty.
I mean,
and this is one of the striking things about when I wrote the book was,
you know,
I've had a lot of success getting people to care about neglected tropical
diseases in Africa and worked with the U S agency for International Development
to support a package of medicines that's now being administered over a billion
people annually.
And now,
you know,
it was one of my proudest accomplishments is,
is helping to raise awareness about neglected tropical diseases.
Like we've been talking about a Hook Korman schistosomiasis in Africa,
Asia,
Latin America.
But the minute I talk about poverty related diseases in the u s the lights go
up.
Why is it,
I don't know.
I can't,
I can't figure out what I'm doing wrong.
I've had so much success getting people to care about NTDs,
neglected tropical diseases and poor developing countries.
But you know,
there has been no response to this,
this book.
I mean it is a,
um,
and,
and the estimates that I come up in the booker,
we have 12 million Americans live in poverty with a neglected tropical disease,
toxic or isis is one of them.
Another one is chagas disease and the list goes on.
And it's been very hard to get people to care about the poor in this country.
That's very strange to me.
And I've always said that about the way we treat other countries where we want
to send them aid and rebuild these countries.
But we don't do anything about these terrible communities that have been
terrible in this country for decades upon decades.
Right.
And so I try to make the point,
the world has changed,
you know,
this,
this old norm of global health developed versus developing.
It still exists,
but it's going away where what we're seeing is our general arise,
uh,
in all,
all economies.
You mean some African countries have eight or 9% economic growth,
but it's all leaving behind a bottom segment of society.
And so I don't care where you show me poverty,
whether it's in Texas or Alabama or Nigeria or Bangladesh.
I will show you these poverty related diseases.
And you know,
I,
I know,
um,
uh,
what's her name?
AOC.
The congresswoman from New York has,
uh,
talked a little bit about hookworm and Alabama.
So last time I was in Washington I dropped off a copy of the book in our office,
but no response yet.
Oh,
she's probably pretty visit too.
Yeah,
she's doing a lot of other stuff.
If you had a magic wand and a,
someone said you could do whatever you want to fix this,
what would you do?
So,
um,
I,
I did meet with a couple of people on the hill and they asked me that question.
What's the magic wand?
And,
um,
there's a couple of things.
One,
we need to actually look for these diseases because the problem is there.
The,
the disease,
they cause a very subtle like developmental delays.
So that if you're a,
you know,
a kid who lives in poverty with developmental delays,
the pediatrician doesn't even think to do a test for toxic psoriasis.
So that Wa,
so we need to raise awareness.
We need to go into poor communities across the country and actually take a blood
test and actually measure for the presence of that disease or that parasite.
Once you find that disease,
what would you do that?
Well,
it depends on the disease.
In some cases we have treatments for,
unlike the treatment for toxic crisis is a five day course of a simple pill of
Albin.
Desal I think hears it and it cures it.
So,
yeah,
so that we have,
you know,
we have interventions.
So one,
you know,
doing what I call active surveillance,
looking for these diseases.
The other one is really trying to understand how these diseases are transmitted.
What is it about poor neighborhoods that is facilitating transmission?
I think the third problem is the diagnostic test themselves because they're very
complicated tests sometimes,
you know,
they are done at the Centers for Disease Control and prevention.
Um,
our lab or National School of Tropical Medicine does a few of them,
but it's not like,
you know,
when you go for a,
you go for blood work and your doctor and you get a little lab slip from quest
diagnostics with the,
you know,
the blood chemistries,
the blood counts,
there's no box there for toxic crisis and chagas disease.
So we need more improved test point of care,
diagnostic tests.
Not just improved tasks but just letting me make it more accessible.
And so they don't have to send it off to the CDC or to,
you know,
our National School of tropical medicine.
Is there a treatment for Toxo?
There is a treatment for toxoplasmosis.
What is it?
Um,
it's a para method means Sulfa drug,
but it requires a long treatment course.
How long?
Uh,
I'd have to look up the number of days.
I haven't treated a patient with toxoplasmosis in a while,
but,
and it kills it effectively.
It can.
Yeah.
Really?
Oh,
I thought it was something you kept for life.
Well,
if you don't get treated right,
yeah.
Okay.
So,
and then if you're immune compromised and it comes back then that that's a
problem as well.
So most people that have it really don't even know they have.
That's right.
Yeah.
And actually in most people who have neglected tropical diseases,
don't know they have it either.
So that in Texas for instance,
we have transmission of a parasitic disease called chagas disease.
It's a cause of heart disease.
Um,
we,
you know,
our fat members of our faculty are,
we're actually able to track down individuals who had donated blood.
Uh,
and the Gulf Coast Regional Blood Authority actually found somebody po people
positive for chagas disease.
They are told to go see your primary healthcare provider.
Uh,
and there are unfortunately the primary health providers not educated about
these diseases and they just assume must be a false positive.
So,
you know,
our faculty attract them down and we're able to get them into treatment.
And what is the treatment for targets?
It's,
um,
it's a,
an anti parasitic agent called bins nit is all,
and that kills it.
That can kill if you catch it early enough,
but sometimes you don't catch it early,
so it becomes systemic than you have then.
That's why we're trying to develop a therapeutic vaccine for this disease.
But again,
it's a therapeutic vaccine for a poverty related disease.
So it's,
it's very tough,
man.
So the point is these diseases are widespread among the poor and we just don't
pay attention to them.
That's great.
And so I think,
you know,
again,
love to hear your thoughts.
I mean,
what is it that,
um,
we just turn our backs on the port in this country.
It's,
uh,
it's disturbing.
It's very,
there's a dismissive attitude and,
and they disproportionately affect people of color as well,
right?
Yeah.
Because,
um,
you know it because it's so linked to poverty.
Well also write slavery.
Yeah.
I mean the history of slavery in this country.
Then the,
the history of systemic racism
in places where they just literally would not sell homes to people who are
African American.
All these things are connected to the see the contribution of maintaining these
impoverished communities.
And there's been almost no effort whatsoever other than the people living in the
community trying to do better and raise everybody up.
There's been no effort whatsoever by the federal government to step in and try
to rehabilitate like a large scale approach to rehabilitating places like the
ghettos of Houston or Baltimore or
Detroit.
You know,
I thought I knew what poverty living on I was before I moved to Texas in 2011 I
was chair of microbiology,
George Washington University,
and I thought,
I thought I knew what poverty looked like.
I moved down to the Gulf coast and it's a different animal.
I mean the,
the depth and breadth of poverty in the Gulf coast and the southern part of the
United States is just extraordinary and it's been very hard to get people to,
um,
want to really take it on and really address these,
these poverty related diseases.
Do you think,
what do you think the cause of it is?
I mean,
if you've,
you've studied this for quite a while.
What the cause of the neglect?
Yes.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know what,
you know,
is it something about American exceptionalism or something?
Like we just don't want to admit we have poor people.
Uh,
I don't know.
You know,
I wasn't the first to come up,
you know,
to raise this issue about poverty.
When I was in high school or junior high school,
I was forced to read a book and at the time I didn't care about it.
It was called the other America.
It was written by,
uh,
fantastic,
um,
social activist named Michael Harrington.
Um,
who was,
uh,
I think someone told me is a very devout Catholic actually.
And so,
and he wrote this book called the other America talks about the hidden poverty
off the road and the actual number of people who live in extreme poverty hasn't
changed since that book was written in the early sixties.
That book was helpful,
was what helped Linden first Kennedy than Lyndon Johnson launched the war on
poverty in 1964 I dusted off that book and it's still,
it still works today.
And that's how I start out talking about my book blue marble health about that
book,
the other America by Michael Harrington.
Yeah.
That is a very strange
thing.
Our acceptance of these communities.
And I mean,
I've always said that if you want to make America a better place,
the best thing to do is not invade other countries or intervene.
The best thing to do is try to rebuild these impoverished communities.
Yeah.
Well,
Gandhi,
Gandhi of people way out.
Gandhi once said,
a civilization is judged by the treatment of its minorities and we're not.
And by that criteria,
we're not doing so well.
You know,
the,
um,
we,
our country was visited by the United Nations special repertoire on poverty.
And into 2017 and his numbers came up with,
we have 19.4 million Americans who live in what's called extreme poverty.
That isn't the U s poverty line.
And roughly around 5 million Americans living on less than $2 a day.
The same benchmark you'd use for global poverty everywhere million.
Yeah.
And,
and guess what?
Those probably all have neglected tropical diseases.
5 million,
just like,
just like those living in extreme poverty in Africa,
the people living on $14 a week to $2 a day.
Yeah.
That's insane.
The University of Michigan Center on poverty is also shown that we have a,
I forget the number,
2.7 million families living on less than $2 a day,
which is probably about the same as the 5 million number.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
And again,
this is not a topic that is very popular.
I mean,
when,
when you see presidential debates this,
this is not something that comes out now.
Nobody talks about it.
And again,
even for disease,
I mean,
what are the diseases we hear about Ebola and diseases like that?
And,
uh,
sometimes some of my frustration,
I say,
you know,
we're,
these are imaginary diseases and yet here we've got widespread diseases of the
poor in the u s and the lights go out.
You remember when that woman came back from Africa and she was a nurse and she
had been,
uh,
some in some connection contacted with Ebola.
She didn't have it and they wanted a quarantine area.
Oh yeah.
And they,
they stuck around in some cabin on the airport or something.
Crazy is terrible.
Yeah.
What did you think about that?
I just thought it was so cruel.
And uh,
is it just a,
an ignorance of how it's transmitted?
How is it transmitted?
Well,
actually Ebola,
you know,
it turns out as the opposite of measles,
measles,
one of those contagious diseases known it has a reproductive number of 12 to 18.
What that means,
if a single individual gets measles,
12 to 18,
others get it because the virus hangs around in the environment and it's so
easily transmissible.
Hangs around like if you touch this table.
That's right.
Or even in the haven,
in the atmosphere.
So I'm,
and that's why you get these really large measles outbreaks like you're seeing
in Washington state.
Um,
and the,
and usually those are infants under the age of 12 months,
not yet old enough.
They vaccinated.
Those are the ones who end up hospitalized and sick.
The,
um,
Ebola is just the opposite.
He ball is a reproductive number of two or three.
So unless you're taking care of a dead or dying,
he bowled a patient or someone who's recently died cause it's only towards the
end stage of the disease that you really get large numbers of virus particles in
the body,
you're not going to get Ebola.
So,
um,
the reason it's being so hard right now to contain a Democratic Republic of
Congo is not because it's so highly contagious,
it's just that the places is decimated by the collapse and infrastructure
associated with civil war.
So even though we have,
and now when Ebola vaccine,
it's hard to vaccinate everybody and how is it transmitted?
Uh,
Ebola by contact with fluids of somebody with,
with the ball.
So it has to get into your tissue somehow.
Right?
Right.
What else should we worry about?
You're freaking me out.
Well,
the point is a lot of these diseases are solvable if,
if we just put our mind to it.
So one of the people are even aware of it.
It was one of the things I say in the book is if,
because these diseases are so widespread among the poor and the g 20 countries,
if we could get the elected,
are the leaders of those g 20 countries together to g 20 summit and say we're
really going to do something about the neglected diseases in our own borders and
I include the United States.
We could get rid of two thirds of the world's poverty related neglected diseases
right off the bat.
Wow.
So a lot of it is political will or ignorance or lack of awareness and political
will.
Well,
it's,
it seems like in this country,
ignorance is a big part of it because a,
this is something I've thought about many times,
but I didn't know about Chaga.
I didn't know about a lot of these other diseases you're describing.
Yeah.
No,
I mean,
so we,
we need to raise awareness about these.
That's why I'm so thrilled.
I'm so thrilled to come here because I've just amplified the number of people
who have heard of this concept of blue marble health is the name that I've given
a different name from global health to,
to separate separated from the two.
Um,
so,
you know,
coming on here is so powerful in terms of amplifying that message.
So again,
back to the magic wand,
but what could be done?
I mean,
is it a funding issue or is it at first before that an education issue?
Well,
I think,
uh,
there's multiple issues.
So I mean,
if again,
the drivers we've been talking today about promoting these diseases,
really tough to do anything about extreme poverty,
um,
war in conflict,
climate change,
clearly there are some things we can do aggressive,
unchecked,
urbanization.
But the other things that you can do is build better tools.
By that I mean better diagnostics,
uh,
better drugs,
better vaccines.
And unfortunately for these poverty related diseases,
there's no market incentive for it.
So it falls to academics,
to professors,
to people trying to do this in the nonprofit sector and we're doing the best we
can,
but it's not nearly as good as having,
uh,
access to getting the pharmaceutical companies involved as well.
And it also seems like this would cost an insane amount of money to just go
through all these poor communities tasks to everyone and started distributing
these,
these drugs and what would pay for all that stuff?
Well,
you know,
some people have asked me,
well,
what would the affordable care act take care of this?
And I said,
well,
we're two steps away from the affordable two,
two s two standard deviation,
two standard deviation,
two degrees of separation away from the affordable care act because we're not
even hearing recognizing these diseases.
Yeah.
You got to know about it first.
I mean,
most people,
what percentage of the population even knows about,
right.
All these parasite created diseases or know that vaccines don't cause autism.
Yeah.
Well that one is,
uh,
that,
that's the biggest one,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
that's a tough one.
And again,
I don't understand it.
I mean I'm just saying it.
I'm saying vaccines don't cause autism cause you're saying it right.
I think this is the part of the boat is a lot of,
part of the problem that we're in this boat with a bunch of people who are
scientifically illiterate like myself were discussing these issues who don't
really know what they're talking.
Like I saw someone talking about tetanus because some boy had a tetanus and he
was a in the hospital for a long time and his bill was hospital bills.
Like $1 million.
Yeah.
Cause it's an ICU admission.
Right,
right.
And they were saying,
hey,
you know,
why didn't this kid get a tetanus shot?
And it again goes back to the same thing,
right?
That people don't want these vaccines than any prevented.
And again,
I don't blame the parents.
I think the parents in some ways they're victims themselves are victim of this
very aggressive misinformation campaign that's out there.
Tetanus is a big one though,
isn't it?
Tetanus.
And we have a vaccine for it.
That's part of the what's called the DPT.
That's one of the first vaccines you get as an infant.
There's no excuse for having a tetanus case in the United States.
Right.
And this kid was unvaccinated.
Right?
Right.
Yeah,
that's my understanding.
Yeah.
I mean,
is there a cure for tetanus outside of vaccines?
Well,
I mean,
there are supportive measures that you can do.
Um,
but you know,
they require hospitalization,
ventilation,
putting on a respirator and you could still die.
So it's a,
it's an awful,
awful disease.
I've seen tetanus working in Central America and elsewhere.
You see a case of technician never forget it.
What is tat miss?
Technically?
Well,
the other name is locked jaw where your muscles go into spasm and um,
and uh,
you and including the muscles involved in breathing so you can't even breathe as
a result of it.
Apparently that freezes the muscles.
What does,
what is doing it?
What's doing is it's parasites actually caused by a bacteria.
The bacteria releases a toxin called tetanus toxin.
That sounds like a horrible way to go.
It's a terror.
I mean these are awful diseases.
And I think one of the things that the anti vaccine group or lobby has I call it
does is they try to be very dismissive of these diseases.
They try to deliberately downplay the effects.
I mean you'll see this stuff on the web.
Measles build your immune system.
I've seen you said it yourself.
I didn't read it.
Yeah,
I just saw it.
That doesn't make any sense.
When they ass it's crap.
Right.
And um,
what,
what are they saying?
What is,
what is the best thing is just a rash and build your immune system.
It makes you stronger.
It's,
it's,
it's something out of from a different planet.
I'm going to wear their,
we do though.
I think the reason for that d becoming popular is because you,
we do kind of helicopter parent our kids a little bit too much and they should
come in contact with a bunch of different things because it does build their
immune system.
Correct.
Well,
an interesting hypothesis called the hygiene hypothesis that says,
um,
you know,
if you kids are living in two sterile environment,
then um,
this can also result in auto immune diseases and things like that.
But allergies,
allergies,
and I have mixed feelings about that hypothesis.
To me it's not,
not here type by any means.
Oh,
you're tight,
but it's there.
There is some sort of a correlation,
particularly between peanut allergies and keeping peanuts away from children and
that there was a study shout those Jonathan hates work in one of his books.
Talked about how there was a study done in communities where they didn't protect
kids from peanut allergies and this much smaller percentage of people developing
peanut allergies versus kids that they did.
Yeah.
Well this is also one of the things that the anti vaccine lobby is doing now
that they're,
you know,
and when I write a book like this,
vaccines don't cause autism.
Now what you're seeing,
remember I told you about that whack-a-mole business where they went from MMR to
thigh,
Marisol to spacing vaccines too close together to aluminum.
Now there's some groups that are moving away from autism altogether and now
they're saying,
well vaccines cause autoimmune disease or vaccines cause other neurologic
deficits.
But it's all,
it's all flimflam.
It's often fun.
It's,
but there are,
there are vaccine courts though,
right?
In vaccines,
there are vaccine courts and they have handed out payments to people who were
injured by vaccines.
Right?
What does,
what does that,
so um,
you know,
it was,
for instance,
if you look over a 10 year period,
I think it is between and haven't looked at the numbers in a while.
I think it's between 2008 and 2014,
2015.
Um,
over that period of time there were 2.5 billion doses of vaccine given 2.5
billion of which the vaccine courts identified around 200 that were a list of
serious injuries that could be that they have a table of that they could
attribute to vaccine.
So there were 2000 payouts.
And of those 2080%,
they didn't really think were attributed to vaccines,
but they paid it out anyway because that's how the courts work.
And then 200 where they can really say,
yeah,
it looks like this could be related to vaccine.
So he divide 200 by 2.5 billion.
That's one in 10 million or even 2000 by 2.5 billion or million and a million.
And these cases,
uh,
what was happening to these people other than the shoulder injury that you were
talking about?
Yeah,
there's a,
there's a list and I talk about it in the book.
There's actually a table you can download it on the web of,
for each vaccine a list of potential injuries that they allow and these
potential engineers.
Uh,
is it,
as we were talking about earlier,
is this just biological variability that some people just react differently to
different things?
I think in some cases we don't know.
Another case is,
you know,
with the live virus vaccines,
if you have,
uh,
a severe and immune deficiency in the,
maybe it wasn't picked up then that then there was that risk.
But you know,
what's,
what's a one in a million?
What's a one in a 10 million risk?
As I said,
we have to keep that in perspective because the gods are getting hit by
lightening is 100 a 700,000.
And if you believe that number or you know,
what's the risk every time you take your child out in a car and drive around the
neighborhood,
I'm sure the risk is far higher than one in a million.
And the real danger is these actual infectious diseases spreading and the damage
they could do damage to the tent and they're coming back.
Yeah.
Meat Measles is,
is,
uh,
is an awful disease,
causes measles and cephalitis measles pneumonia.
I find that a lot of people that are,
um,
that are steadfast in their,
uh,
resistance to vaccines,
they also believe in a lot of other questionable things.
It seems like these things get lumped into these groups of things that they
don't trust the government about.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
I think that's part,
I think that's probably true.
Yeah.
That's what it said.
Which was she government,
which was,
well,
you know,
it was interesting.
So,
you know,
I said,
we know we need to hear from the Centers for disease control and more in the
surgeon general and now they're starting to speak out.
But you know the people counter that said,
well,
part of the problem was people don't trust their government.
And I say,
well that's true of some,
but I think most people,
if you know,
if we had a more visible public health force out there,
people would listen to it.
Well,
I think that what you're talking about in terms of these poor neighborhoods and
these parasites getting into people's system and affecting cognitive development
and what it was,
the other one besides the Chaga,
it was that toxic.
Uriah says cognitive development.
The fact that there's actual cures for these things too.
I mean that I estimated an a paper,
there are 2.8 million African Americans living in poverty with toxic horizons.
Wow.
This is not a rare disease,
Joe.
This is,
this is a common disease unknown,
but it's occurring among the poor and it's a chronic and debilitating affection.
It's not dramatic.
It's not a 90 bullets not killing people.
And is this mostly climates as well?
It's probably,
it's more common in the south and the north.
Is it because they've long,
longer time to do this because the eggs are,
the eggs are in the environment and the worm develops within the egg.
Is there any other diseases that are going on that we don't know about?
Um,
yeah.
Varna wearable.
Yeah,
sure.
Um,
there's other,
there's a brain parasitic infection called cysticercosis that one is from eggs,
um,
often from individuals who have a tapeworm.
Uh,
so that's where we're seeing cases of that.
Um,
there's,
uh,
some of the viruses transmitted by mosquitoes.
One of the ones we don't talk about a lot,
which is a very serious infection,
is West Nile virus infection.
That's got very high rates of not only encephalitis,
but also one of our faculty members.
Christie Marie is showing very high rates of depression and other neurologic
debilitation four.
And that's another one we could probably use a vaccine for,
but there isn't the market incentive to do it.
West Nile virus does come up though the,
at least that's discussed in the news and people are aware of it,
right?
You said it right,
but there's no vaccine,
there's no vaccine,
but there could be,
what does it,
there could be what's holding it back?
What's holding it back is lack of market forces,
lack of financial incentive for the pharmaceutical companies to take it off.
Um,
so it's,
there's an extremely large investment to develop something along those lines.
That's right.
On vaccines are from an investor's perspective,
tough sell because you know,
there's a possibility,
you know,
first of all,
you need many years of clinical trials.
It can sometimes take two decades from the original conception of a vaccine to
actually going through a clinical trial.
So the hook vaccine,
I've been working on a,
we've been doing it,
uh,
since the 1990s.
So we're talking decades long time horizons.
When you talk to an investor about something with decades long time horizons,
you figure it out,
right?
The light,
the lights go out.
I mean the,
uh,
very,
very quickly.
So we're,
it gets gross,
right?
Because this is all,
we were relying on these private businesses to invest money to cure a public
health issue.
That's right.
That seems kind of crazy.
Well,
so in response to that,
what happened was after the Ebola fiasco in 2014,
where we didn't have any bowl of vaccine and Guinea,
Liberia and Sierra Leone,
a group of individuals came together,
a Davos,
the World Economic Forum and um,
and including the gates foundation and they,
uh,
put around,
they put,
developed this concept or which an organization called Sepi the coalition for
epidemic preparedness innovation to incentivize,
uh,
biotechs and pharmaceutical companies to embark on a diseases for which of
pandemic potential like Ebola,
like last of fever,
like mirrors,
coronavirus infection.
And that was great.
But the problem was they didn't address these poverty related diseases.
So those of us who were working on poverty related diseases are still kind of on
the outside looking in.
It just seems like having everything managed by private companies that need to,
they,
they need to have some sort of a financial incentive to attack these diseases.
That seems like a crazy way to deal with health crisis.
That's right.
And so what I've recommended,
as I said that organization's Sepi is great for what it's doing,
but we need another mechanism.
What I've proposed is that,
um,
since these diseases are so common among the poor and the g 20 countries,
these are the 20 largest economies to put together public sector funds for that
purpose.
Public sector funds for investing in developing vaccines and treatments for
poverty related diseases,
these chronic debilitating diseases.
And in fact,
you know,
we can show that the using working with health economists,
we actually work with a terrific health economist.
His name is Bruce Lee.
Evolve all names.
He's a professor at Johns Hopkins in Ai Right now.
He loves it.
Um,
um,
and he's able to,
he's been able to show that our vaccines are not only cost effective,
there cost savings,
meaning that they're economically dominant,
that they'll actually save money.
The problem is you still doesn't help you with the fact that you still need
some,
but the return is on public health.
You still need somebody to come along and provide that investment.
So you know,
so what's happened is our,
our technical ability to develop vaccines has outstripped our,
our,
our financial instruments that we have to do it.
So I get a stream of young people,
uh,
in my office wanting to go into global health.
I mean the commitment for this next generation and know they get a lot of bad
press,
but my impression is this next generation,
their commitment,
the public services and an all time high and they say,
you know,
Doctor Hotez,
I'm all in,
I'm going to go into global health.
And there are a little bit disappointed when I tell them get an Mba or get a law
degree because where we need the innovation now is in the,
it's in the finance sector,
there is a,
there must be a business model out there that would work that would figure out
how to do this.
I just don't have the background to do it.
It seems like once the momentum is in the corner of this being handled by the
private sector,
and that the private sector has to develop these vaccines and these treatments,
and they have to do it with some sort of financial incentive.
If they don't have a bucket of gold at the end of the rainbow,
they're not going to take a ride.
That's right.
So that's crazy.
It's crazy.
But that's
the reality.
And so,
um,
what the exciting thing about what I do is,
you know,
developing these vaccines for poverty related diseases is,
there's no roadmap right now.
There were in clinical trials,
I don't know what the roadmap is to get to licensure and getting these vaccines
out to the public.
The terrifying thing to think it keeps me up at night is there's no roadmap.
Right.
Both good.
It's not good.
Yeah.
There is.
Oh,
how much does it cost to get a vaccine?
I mean,
in general,
from developmental period too.
Social application.
Well,
the pharmaceutical companies have traditionally said billions,
but I don't think that's the case.
I think one of the reasons why
they're doing that is because they're also recovering their r and d costs.
You know,
they're putting money into r and d that they,
that they re that they charge in order to either make a profit or at least to
eve.
And so for instance,
the cervical cancer vaccine,
the HPV vaccine that,
you know,
when I last look was $420 for the three doses,
it doesn't take cost $420 to make that vaccine it,
it's just that they're recovering their r and d costs,
which is,
which is fair enough.
So one of the things that we're proposing to do for our neglected disease
vaccines is we'll d link the R and d costs and other was if we've gotten grants,
whether it's from the gates foundation in the past or,
or the Nih or the European Union or the Dutch government or the Carlos Slim
Foundation,
we're not going to pass those costs on a,
we'll just,
you know,
that was used for r and d and we would just cost for the cost of goods so at
least we can get it down to just a couple of dollars,
a dose,
a few dollars a dose.
Now for anybody that's listening to this conversation and they have additional
questions,
where's the best place that you should guide them?
It would it be your books?
Probably the books.
Cause I wrote the books for lay audiences and lay audiences sort of,
I mean somebody with a college or university education,
but I mean they're not,
you know,
it's there.
They're published by Johns Hopkins University Press.
So,
and they are kind of,
they're uneven in terms of how weighty they get into the science.
But certainly the vaccine's not because Rachel is autism.
I wrote it with the idea of parents vaccine hesitant parents and also the
pediatricians because the other problem with pediatrician says,
you know,
they're,
they're in their office and parents are reading the stuff on the Internet and
they come and loaded,
loaded for bear into the pediatrician's office with all these factoids.
And the pediatrician was like,
well gee,
I'd never heard that before.
And then the pediatrician has made to feel stupid.
Like he's not keeping up with the science he is or she is,
but it's just,
they're not keeping up with the misinformation.
So I provide talking points in the epilogue of the book and Blue Marble health
is the best resource for people to understand these about diseases of the poor
and wealthy countries.
And then I have a third book that I wrote a few years ago called forgotten
people,
forgotten diseases that describes the neglected tropical diseases.
Well,
I really hope that what comes out of this is someone gets motivated to create
some sort of a documentary really on both subjects.
I mean,
I think that we would greatly benefit from some clarity for people that do have
concern about autism.
That's in a digestible form for good or for bad.
People like to watch documentaries.
And I hope you don't get too beat up over this.
Uh,
because I know the anti vaccine groups are very passionate and well,
I mean,
they have a position they'd be,
I don't know why they would beat me up.
That's why they beat me up a lot.
I'm sure they go after you and they already called me a shell.
They call me a shell for a lot of things.
They'll be leaving the round earth.
Jamie has a,
a a t shirt that he sells@youngjamie.com.
It's round Earth Shell,
right?
Literally,
I've been called a round earth shale will give the earth is flat.
There's a lot of those.
I don't know if you know,
I didn't know that.
There's a lot,
so you get beat up no matter what if you're talking.
But,
um,
so,
uh,
but I really think it would be,
it would do a good service if somebody did put together a documentary because I
don't think most people are aware.
I think most people are just relying on this fear like that vaccines do cause
autism.
Um,
there's
also this connection between people that are older,
correct.
When when they're older and they have children,
there seems to be more likely there seems to be,
and that may be related to as you get older,
your sperm or your egg have some genetic instability and more likely to purchase
mutations.
Yes.
That's probably the Mac and that would go hand in hand.
Yeah.
The genetic basis of autism.
Um,
and then the blue marble health book,
I mean,
what,
what you've been saying today about these diseases and how many of them exist
and how many of them are almost unknown,
untreated,
undiagnosed and just how many people are unaware.
Um,
I really hope that someone does something about that too.
But in the meantime,
people can buy your books.
Are they available in audio as well?
Um,
definitely the vaccines lock because Rachel's autism is audio books and I'm not
sure about blue marble health.
Okay.
But you can get it on Amazon.
Well,
thanks for being here.
Appreciate it.
It's good to see you again.
Well,
thank you for raising awareness of all this stuff.
I really,
my pleasure.
My pleasure.
And I appreciate you coming down here and explaining a lot of this stuff for us.
It's been a great time.
I really enjoyed the opportunity.
Um,
if people want to get ahold of you on Twitter,
what is your Twitter handle at Peter Hotez.
Okay,
thanks sir.
Appreciate you.
Hmm.